so I remember like I was trying to play
trucks with these boys and they're like
we can't play trucks with you because my
brother says you're a Mariposa what's
that mean my brother says you're a
butterfly which is a derogatory way of
saying you're you're gay
and I was like what do you what like I
and then I knew it was bad and it was
bad because I felt it and I felt that it
felt bad to be this because you don't
like it and you don't like me being this
and it was like they kept chanting it
and I was like why do I play with you
anyways and I grabbed my Tonka truck and
I walked away and they kept chanting it
over and they and then I felt something
fly to the side of my ear and then I
turned around and it just like rocks
flying towards me and one of them hit me
right here where I have this car and I
just remember like a gash my face and
just blood gushing over my face running
to my mom screaming I was like
and my mom just looked at me and then
she said
like who cares that they call you
butterfly butterflies are beautiful and
I just remember thinking it was okay but
I know she was making me feel better